[Musique]
bienvenue bonjour c'est déjà le mois de
mai pour paris saclay tv nous allons
vous faire vivre en avant-première paris
saclay spring quatrième édition enfin en
présentiel ce sera les 12 et 13 mai
prochains alors pour faire découvrir cet
événement aux journalistes une visite de
presse a été organisée sur votre
territoire pour découvrir cet écosystème
unique musique et au sommaire aussi le
pea paris sac est doublement récompensé
le voici lauréat du pays à 4 le
programme d'investissements d'avenir
pour son démonstrateur agro urbain de
kobo vide un quartier stratégique
connaissez-vous horiba ce groupe
japonais a été l'un des premiers à
s'implanter ici sur le territoire de
paris saclay sa filiale française est
donc là depuis 2012 et c'est un vrai
succès nous avons rencontré son
président laurent fulham enfin nous vous
avions invité à participer au marché des
producteurs locaux dans le quartier de
moulins qui est juste à côté
initiative impulsée par la miam local
circuits courts démarche solidaire vous
étiez nombreux au rendez-vous et enfin
notre agenda ce sera à la fin de cette
émission
c'est le rendez vous incontournable du
mois de mai paris saclay spring
quatrième édition enfin en présentiel ce
sera les 12 et 13 mai prochains deux
jours pour découvrir votre territoire
deux jours pour découvrir le meilleur de
l'innovation industrielle et durable
votre territoire c'est bien simple c'est
15% de la recherche française se soucier
un écosystème unique alors pour mieux
sensibiliser pour mieux informer les
journalistes le pea paris saclay a
organisé une visite de presse ses
journalistes ont pu se rendre sur
différents sites nous les avons
accompagnés reportage
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on organisait une visite de
presse à paris saclay sur sur saint
quentin en yvelines et ensuite sur la
paris saclay en essonne donc sur le
campus urbain nous nous trouvons
actuellement pour montrer l'excellence
académique et l'excellence industrielle
que nous avons ici sur paris saclay et
parce que nous sommes six semaines avant
l'événement paris saclay spring qui est
notre grand rendez vous annuel de
l'innovation et donc l'idée c'était de
montrer aux journalistes ou en été paris
saclay en 2022 et puisqu'on va pouvoir
leur montrer le jour j ai donc le jour
de l'événement le 12 mai à paris saclay
sur le campus de l'école polytechnique
alors on avait axé notre présentation
sur la filière santé qui est une de nos
sept grandes filières d'excellence
industrielle à paris saclay la santé
c'est 40 % de nos startups aujourd'hui
ici sur le territoire donc aujourd'hui
on a présenté sky therapeutics qui est
une start up qui est actuellement un
cube est hébergé dans la faculté de
médecine de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines qui est une
des composantes de l'université paris
saclay et qui travaille sur la myopathie
de duchenne on a également ce matin en
fin de matinée présenter et pilar mais
qui travaille sur un appareil de
diagnostic rapide de la tuberculose qui
est une pandémie aujourd'hui un peu plus
silencieuse un peu moins visible mais
qui est toujours là et contre laquelle
il faut évidemment lutte et du mieux
possible et qui elle est incubé à
l'incubateur draps x de l'école
polytechnique donc voilà deux cas
d'école qui nous montre bien la richesse
de cet écosystème pour la santé
l'innovation en santé dans les
biotechnologies dans la pharmaceutique
notamment
sprint ce sera sa quatrième édition est
le 12 et 13 mai prochains donc le 12 mai
sur le campus de l'école polytechnique
on aura à la fois un village des
villages d'exposition donc un showroom
technologique où on pourra découvrir les
prototypes les solutions les produits
d'une cinquantaine de start up qui ont
été sélectionnés on a créé un label pour
ça qu'ils s'appellent sprint 50 donc on
pourra à la fois avoir leur stand leurs
produits à la fois les ententes pitcher
dans un concours de pitch où elles
s'affrontent sur le plateau télé qu'on
met en place pour l'événement donc ça ce
sera à la fin présentiel et à la fois
retransmis sur internet et puis
évidemment paris saclay springs est
avant tout une occasion de faire des
rencontres et donc c'est des rendez vous
d'affaires qui se déroule sur les deux
jours les 12 et 13 mai l'événement est
entièrement accessible à distance pour
ceux qui ne pourraient pas nous
rejoindre sauf la partie sur une
technologie qui elle est vraiment en
présentiel dans l'école polytechnique
[Musique]
horiba a été parmi les premiers à
s'installer sur votre territoire c'était
en 2012 ce groupe japonais propose des
solutions de mesure pour l'industrie et
la science il cherche aussi à développer
des partenariats à dénicher de nouveaux
talents d'où le choix de paris saclay
d'ailleurs ils ont besoin de renfort
vous allez l'entendre rencontre avec le
président de la filiale française
laurent fut l'anah
[Applaudissements]
horiba est un groupe japonais aurient
bat france et une de ses filiales où est
basé un centre d'excellence horiba
fournit des solutions de mesure de
métrologie pour la science et
l'industrie et notre raison d'être est
d'accélérer l'innovation par la
connaissance
le focus de notre développement est
aujourd'hui dans des domaines de
l'énergie et les matériaux mais
également les sciences de la vie et puis
les semi conducteurs dans les trois cas
on apporte par le croisement de
technologie historiquement technologies
optiques des solutions innovantes qui
nous permettent
d'accélérer le développement chez nos
clients de nouveaux produits donc on
intervient dans les domaines de la r&d
mais également dans le domaine de la
production pour faire du contrôle de
procédé et améliorer le contrôle qualité
et la productivité de nos clients
horiba était visionnaire de s'installer
sur le plateau de saclay dès 2012 donc
fait partie des premières sociétés à
avoir choisi
palaiseau et le plateau de saclay pour
son implantation pour son centre
d'excellence
ça c'est pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
pour l'environnement académique on
cherche à attirer des talents dans le
domaine de la recherche qui nous
aideront à concevoir les instruments de
demain on cherche également à dans le
développement de ces instruments a
collaboré étroitement avec un tissu
académique proches également il est
important d'avoir des partenaires
industriels
qui vont pouvoir nous aider à développer
les bons produits en volume et depuis un
certain nombre d'années dans le domaine
de l'énergie mais également dans le
domaine des sciences de la vie on voit
de plus en plus de partenaires
industriels qui peuvent remplir cette
fonction est donc l'écosystème à la fois
académique et industriel est un gros
plus pour nous et puis enfin au niveau
des talents pour nous il est important
de pouvoir
être dans un
un pôle qui a tiré et fait grandir des
étudiants qui deviendront les employés
de riba de demain on a presque une
centaine de postes aujourd'hui ouvert et
donc on recrute dans tous les domaines
on a besoin aujourd'hui de beaucoup de
renforts et je vous invite à rejoindre
une société en pleine dynamique qui
travaillent sur des problématiques
sociétales d'avenir et où il ya une
véritable passion de la technologie
[Musique]
innovation et développement durable
c'est le mantra de le paix à paris
saclay le pea qui se voit aujourd'hui
doublement récompensé deux projets qui
concernent ce quartier le corbusier avec
donc ce projet du démonstrateur agro
urba de corneville sélectionnés dans le
cadre de la mit l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt démonstrateur de la ville
durable en fait il s'agit de réduire la
vulnérabilité des habitants face aux
changements climatiques et de les
accompagner lors des différentes crises
dans le cadre des démonstrateurs de la
ville durable du quatrième programme
d'investissements d'avenir france 2030
le fait à paris saclay la communauté
d'agglomération paris saclay les
communes dorcé de saclay le groupe
hospitalier nord-essonne
l'inra et et le cabinet et vous loupé se
sont associés pour porter un projet sur
corps de ville d'atténuation et
d'adaptation
des activités des usagers de ce quartier
au changement climatique
c'est le projet qu'on appelle le
démonstrateur agro urbain de cordes
ville au coeur du campus urbain de paris
saclay qui a l'ambition de s'appuyer sur
ses ressources ses spécificités et ses
capacités pour être un quartier sobre
favorisant la circularité des matières
et
la résilience ainsi nous avons
l'ambition de travailler sur la
diminution des îlots de chaleur urbains
de promouvoir un aménagement favorables
à la santé nous avons également
l'ambition de favoriser la circularité
des matières notamment de travailler sur
le cycle de l'eau en analysant les
possibilités de réutilisation des eaux
grises des eaux usées pour un maximum d'
usage voire même peut-être à des fins de
potabilisation également de travailler
sur le cycle de la zot par la
valorisation des urines par une collecte
séparative d urine dans les bâtiments
qui peut ensuite servir d'intrants dans
les champs agricoles qui sont juste à
côté au lieu d'utiliser des engrais
chimiques
également de travailler sur les
matériaux biosourcés dans la
construction avec notamment la proximité
de la paille là encore petit se situe à
proximité avec l'agriculture qui est
voisine de ce projet urbain en essayant
de voir comment une filière pourrait
peut-être se structurer par la
construction en bail mais également sur
la construction en chambre sur la
construction terre également nous avons
beaucoup de terres excavées avec nos
chantiers et enfin
la dernière action portera sur la
plateforme expérimentale agricole qui en
lisière nord du projet urbain dans
laquelle avec l'inra et agroparistech
nous allons pouvoir faire un certain
nombre d'expérimentations sur
l'évolution et la transition agro
écologique de l'agriculture sur un
certain nombre de cultures également sur
la valorisation organique des déchets il
y aura également des jardins partagés
qui pourront être ouverts aux habitants
de ce quartier et de manière
transversale l'ensemble de ces
dynamiques doit doit aider à faire
travailler ensemble l'ensemble des
parties prenantes mais également de
mobiliser beaucoup les usagers pour
faire en sorte qu'ils aient davantage de
participation dans la construction de ce
quartier et que la fabrique de la ville
et de manière plus générale au campus
urbain se fasse par et pour les usagers
[Musique]
le développement durable il passe aussi
par le marché des produits locaux
initiative portée par l'amiable locale
ce marché il a eu lieu ici dans le
quartier de moulins l'objectif favoriser
les produits locaux évidemment les
circuits courts et surtout en faire
profiter les étudiants notamment les
plus précaires grâce à l'association
agora est un événement gourmand donc
mais aussi musical festif grâce à
l'accord parade ou non les enfants
étaient à la fête regardez
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est sur le mile pierre
potier dans le quartier de moulins à
gif-sur-yvette
pour un marché de producteurs le second
qui a pour but de favoriser les produits
locaux en circuit court avec la présence
d'une petite vingtaine de producteurs
qui qui sont présents dans la même
localité le marché est organisé en
collaboration avec la mairie gifle et le
père
le marché en fait là pour but d'aider
l'association agora é pa ris à pied qui
une association étudiante qui vient en
aide aux étudiants précaires pour
l'université de paris saclay je leur
donne aujourd'hui mais n'est jamais vu
dans la boutique ne je crois que je
faisais pas assez donc
je suis et pourquoi pas faire d un
marché producteurs avec des producteurs
qui sont partants soit les 2/3 connaît
une vingtaine de producteurs et les
bénéfices ont totalement reversés à
l'association
les producteurs sont à moins de 200 km
parce que sur le principe de la boutique
on arrive à voir aujourd'hui 80 % des
producteurs sur les cendres de la
présence en boutique à moins de 80 km
aujourd'hui on a du coup 17 producteurs
qui sont de la région ile de france
evelyne et sommes principalement et pas
mettre dehors et loire également qu'il
ya un gros sourcier pour moi de deux
producteurs
le marché se déroule de 9h30 à 18h avec
une animation à 12 heures et à 16 heures
via la fanfare de centrale supélec la
bande à joe et il ya aussi un manège
éphémère écologique où les parents sont
invités à pédaler pour faire prenez le
manège
[Musique]
le pays a mis en place également une
exposition éphémère sur les bâtiments
vacants
[Musique]
c'est le deuxième marché en six mois
l'objectif peut réussir en faire deux
par an 1 pour la rentrée de septembre
est un pur grimpeur
[Musique]
à la une de notre agenda paris saclay
spring évidemment rendez vous est pris
les 12 et 13 mai pour cette nouvelle
édition en présentiel les inscriptions
sont ouvertes toutes les informations
sur le site dont le lien s'affiche sur
votre écran mais d'abord pourquoi ne pas
vous lancer dans notre chantier
participatif
venez construire un pavillon réciproque
alors du 4 au 15 avril joignez vous à
l'équipe de constructeurs du pavillon
pour la pose des platelages en bois de
la terrasse c'est de 12h à 15h et du 2
au 6 mai venez participer à la
construction du lanterneaux cette fois
c'est de 13h30 à 16h30 le printemps est
là enfin presque laissez vous tenter par
cette balade organisée en partenariat
avec le comité départemental de
randonnée pédestre de l'essonne c'est le
23 avril venez découvrir les rigoles de
vauhallan près de 11 km de balade avec
un super goûter à l'arrivée si vous êtes
plutôt cinéphiles le cinoche organise sa
première nuit du cinéma le samedi 9
avril venez partager un moment unique
avec trois films cultes sur grand écran
plus de précisions là aussi sur le lien
qui s'affiche voilà de quoi vous occuper
pour les semaines à venir par est sacré
tv c'est déjà terminé on se retrouve
très vite pour un prochain numéro mais
d'ici là restez informés grâce au site
ep attiré paris tiré saclay point fr à
bientôt
[Musique]